so what's going on with july 31st
so we have a debt ceiling coming up so
the nation
has an agreed upon limit
in terms of as much as we can borrow as
many treasury bills notes bonds as we
can sell
and once you hit the debt ceiling and
they negotiated this
july of 2019 that picture i sent you
once once they hit the debt ceiling
which is july 31st
2021 the treasury can't sell anything
else
no more issuing debt so you have to live
off of what you have
in your checking account basically plus
what's coming into the in
into government revenues until the
democrats and the republicans get
together
and agree upon what republicans are
saying right now is
big spending cuts now adam are democrats
going to agree to big spending cuts
that doesn't seem to be their um agenda
here's your friend
janet yellen right here treasury
secretary janet yellen warns of
absolutely catastrophic hit to the
economic recovery this summer if u.s
can't pay its bills on time i mean
i mean that's a good picture of janet
yellen she looks good a picture
she looks like mrs magoo who's scared
anyways um
good pick okay somebody understood that
kudos to somebody come here adam
yeah no finish your cereal
i put it on the floor for you eat up
worse counselors develop
some strong proteins like in 2011
the the debt of the country was
downgraded stock market went down 17
can you tell me what it would feel like
today at the stock market went down 17
the 10-year bond the 10-year bond yield
fell 100 bases a full percentage point
can you imagine waking up tomorrow and
being like the 10-year yield is
0.47 what excuse me but that's what
happened in 2011 because the
the debt fight was so contentious the
republicans were so pissed off about
obamacare
so so mad they had just won the midterms
and right now mcconnell's like i got my
eye on the prize
get out of here let me tell you it's
going to get very ugly it's going to get
very ugly very ugly because they're not
going to agree so it's 7 31 there's
how long do you think it's going to take
till they come up so i i did the math
because we published on this yesterday
it looks like the government has enough
money to run
probably through september 20. look
congress the house of representatives
after
it leaves for the july 4th break it's in
session
nine days after after that in the month
of july before it leaves for
august the whole month the first day
after
the first day after july 31st that there
can be
could you just set the chills
interesting i just got the chills the
first time that there can be a vote
after july 31st which is when the debt
limit is hit
is september the 20th after 6 30 p.m
wait
wait wait wait wait wait do you have any
favorite go back go back for a second so
okay so break that down if i'm a small
business walk
give it to me as if i'm a small business
july 31st i no longer have money i i
no longer can issue debt i can no longer
get any more debt
okay i can't do it so now what if i'm a
small business uncle sam
goes to the bank and they're like sorry
you're cut off that's it
and i have only enough cash in reserves
to last two months
well by then the the treasury
the treasury checking account by then
should be down to about
400 billion dollars 450 billion
well we're running at about 50 billion
dollars a week right now
is our is our burn rate yeah that's
nothing
well it it does not last long and then
if you go back and
you go you go back to 2011 go back to
2013. i loved it
then you start to close non-essential
government agencies i mean we forget the
smithsonian is closed
and then you start furloughing
government employees i love this
well this happened in 2017 when uh
you know the infamous uh chuck schumer
nancy pelosi meeting with trump in the
office any other they're gonna blame it
on you he's like i don't care
blame it on me they shut it down let me
ask you guys a question by the way 66
of senators in this country are over the
age of 60. yeah
and they're 15 of the population 66
over 16. over the age of 60 in the
center
as a nation demographically speaking are
young or not represented
you know you know why i love this let me
qualify why i love this and i want to
hear your your thoughts and questions
you know why i love this
let me tell you why i love this because
it's forcing the two sides to get into a
room
oh and chop it up you're forced to
negotiate
you don't have a choice mcconnell said
of 2011 because
they've all been around forever right
you got to dust these people off they're
so old
but mcconnell said of 2007. some of my
colleagues in the gop
thought that the debt ceiling standoff
that they should have shot the hostage
he said no no no what we learned is that
it's best
to collect the ransom this is the man
who's going to be negotiating
with the democrats he's not a guy you
want to negotiate with all he wants to
do is
use this as a platform for the midterms
okay
guess anybody either of you guess how
many houses
how many seats in the house of
representatives are needed to flip the
senate
back red how many seconds how many seats
say the question again
senate what senator what is the house of
representatives
what is the democratic majority oh it's
less than 12 i want to say at this point
wait you're saying one
i i thought it's like seven or nine what
is it
five okay five well it was it was a big
number just uh just a while back so it's
now five
because that's not a big number though
no it's no this is the most
razor thin majority in the past century
wow that's how little work mcconnell has
to do
they just need they need one what
that's crazy kai look
this is like you know this is impressive
but i mean and they need one
obviously and joe manchin is like a foe
republican at this point
by the way who wrote the 1.2 trillion
dollar infrastructure bill
wrote it why doesn't he run though joe
manchin
he run what as for president why doesn't
a guy like
that run yes and see that's the question
that's the thing for all these
conspiracy theories the fact that joe
manchin is the most powerful politician
man of the person of your time magazine
my opinion the biggest
super economy in the world until china
catches up he's the most powerful person
in the country
and what does that say to you it says
that the country is
not full of conspiracy theorists it's
that the moderates don't have a voice
but joe manchin is the poster child for
democrats
and republicans because he's straight
down the middle oh down the middle i've
heard that somewhere oh
so um there's a show on the youtube
channel
with the martino booth i don't know if
you guys have heard about it
that's why he's so powerful because but
he wrote the infrastructure bill i love
it
he wrote it personally and by the way
back in 2011
another little parallel the spending
cuts that they finally agreed upon
that was just clawing back money from
from funds that had not been spent
that's what this infrastructure bill is
it's like 589 billion
plus in order to get to 1.2 trillion
they're clawing back funds that were
cove
covered relief programs that weren't
spent yeah so that's why the democrats
are losing their minds
they're like no no no we want fresh debt
and jay powell's sitting over it
at the eccles building in the federal
reserve going wait a minute i need i
need to buy i need stuff to buy here
well let me i need a treasury
is there any law that can amend the 731
is there anybody that can come up all of
a sudden there's this one
law and rule that we have that they can
come out and say no we can extend it for
another three months or six months or
not
actually already has been okay guys just
bear with me for two seconds i'm getting
in the weeds here go for it
the law dictates if you're watching us
you're enjoying this smash the thumbs up
if you're enjoying what danielle has to
do to help us with the algorithms and
subscribe to the channel as well go
ahead continue and take notes
um so the law says that
the uncle sam's checking account which
is held at the federal reserve
needs to be back to the balance that it
was on
in in july of 2019 when the agreement
was made
so you've got to run the money down
because you're not allowed to go into
the fight with extra
padding in your checking account you
have to bring it back down to 120 130
billion dollars which is where it was
july of 2019.
mnuchin steve
thinking that there would be all this
fun funding to spend
ran up the balance to 1.8 trillion
dollars
so it's just now it's 600 billion today
so
it's been run down but janet yellen is
technically going into this fight
with three and a half times the
ammunition of what the law allows
but it's because of trump overspending
that she's got this cushion oh the irony
wow so trump held you helped yellen out
yes
absolutely that's hilarious so there's
but there's but that's okay
mcconnell he's he's he's like i'm i'm
fine
50 bill a week is what our rent burn
rate that's our
that's our average since the 1st of may
400 billion
which is what we have tax payments and
all that yeah so 400 billion so that
means so so let's just say
if mcconnell is going to negotiate
mcconnell doesn't want to negotiate
first week of august not the second week
of august not the fourth week of august
macaulay wants to negotiate
no congress is not in session in august
congress is closed they're all no matter
what it's september
september the 20th at 6 30 pm is the
first time that a vote can come to the
floor of the house of representatives
that is the congressional
calendar it's not going to be pretty and
that was why the summer
of 2011 was a show so give us my
friend sorry
give us the good bad ugly give us here's
what ugly looks like this is what could
happen
here's what's the good that can look
like they can come in they can agree
they can get out give us a good battle
the democrats can agree to all these
spending cuts okay cut out the fat
which is not something that's not the
remote program
somebody said six trillion dollars in in
in in social spending get that
everything bye-bye yep your entire
agenda goodbye
so that way they kiss goodbye at the
midterms or the republicans can hold
their ground
and democrats still kiss goodbye the
midterms
but they're not so best scenario they're
losing midterms best case
if let's put it this way in a i always i
always look at
there's there's a website um media
something where you actually can put
the source that you're you're looking at
and they they put it on a spectrum
of left leaning right leaning whether
it's an organization a
publication a newspaper cnn whatever so
you put cnn up there and
it's going to go way left you put news
max up there it's going to go way right
so i checked out the publication and it
was smack dab in the middle okay
pull it up and um it's like media bias
something something
but i i so the publications right smack
in the middle
moderate and it was like the republicans
have this midterm to lose it is theirs
to lose because
of the razor thin majority of the
democrats i mean a monkey could swing
five
a monkey could swing five seats in the
house
and mitch mcconnell might be that monkey
again he's already said i'm not
a turtle he's already said that the debt
ceiling fight's not a hostage
you're is that the website allsides.com
or
no it's like media bias fact check
google media buys fact check
buy is fast now go put go put cnn on it
just for fun so you put search
yep cnn
left bias where do you see it left bias
these media sources are moderately this
strongly biased towards liberal causes
through story selection and they tell
you how good their fact checking is
oh whether they're not biased fact check
and then you can
then you can put newsmax up there
complete opposite side
newsmax
questionable source of course that's one
of the more following extreme
extreme consistent promotions put fox
news up there
see fox is going to be fox is going to
be right newsmax
newsmax was too extreme right by
right-back moderate to strongly biased
towards conservatives how about media
matters type in media matters
never heard of it media not media media
yeah media matters
al qaeda from norway
left bias okay all right
guys can i can i it's a great report
type in drudge
report right oh my gosh it's going to be
like off the richter scale
but i'm curious to know what it says
right center bias there you go
right center so they are considered to
be more moderate and more moderate
than fox news i put up this little
channel called valuetainment let's see
where they're at on this so maybe they
get uh that's going to be like off the
right
no way we're in the rain or in the
middle baby no we have you here as
balanced
exactly we're fair and bad look at that
there's a million different
facts in truth facts and truth
let me let me circle back here we're
getting a little but all i'm saying is
this this is something to to bookmark
put the link
below in the comment section chat it's
good danielle let me ask you when you
read something or you see something
go check the source code go see what
their agenda is let's get back to
anyways let's get back to helping our
our fellow man and woman out there okay
we got a little wonky here with the
dates and the times and the
and the debates and what what might
happen yeah a little too much for you
no no no no no i'm just saying we hear
this i want to stress this guy out
you're supposed to be fun for this yeah
it should be fun it should be
a news flash let's make this fun this is
a poster
obtainment adam has one interest it's
just payment
yeah that's what he has yeah but tell us
the cat's out the back i'm all about
that
so the numbers
tell us what you're worried about we
hear about this every year the debt
ceiling
and we're going to talk about this and
we're now we're good
go ahead the debt ceiling and we're
running out of money
and every year it's like this hostage
situation the government's going to take
over
i'm halfway through okay but every year
it's the same
it's uh yeah they figured it out you
know it's kind of like a superhero movie
it's like ah
is the world gonna oh no they saved the
world oh my god is this gonna
uh they figured it out so like what's
gonna be different this time even when
the government shut down in 2017
the only people that are affected were
the government employees that basically
didn't get two paychecks
and then they got caught up wait a
minute that's what i'm saying we're
making the debt ceiling
hey hey buddy this is great news you
know why here's
let me simplify it for you please do as
if you've got it's as if you got a
credit card
that's 10 grand and you're at
dollars okay and you got four hundred
dollars left that's phenomenal stop
overspending
i agree i don't think we have a credit
limit i mean what that does is
it doesn't say a problem it doesn't say
it's the end of the world you know what
it is a problem
no you know what it says it doesn't say
it's under the world it says
change your habits change your spending
habits that's all it is to me
this is you sas talks money yeah you do
your se
your your principles that you talk about
okay that's helped you go from
zeroing cash sleeping on your friend's
bed in colorado
how much money did you have at the time
i was broke because you were broke
did you have it you're right you're a
cash millionaire
why why are you cash millionaire today
because what what did you change
what did you change well income and cash
flow but also
expenditures and saving and the last
thing the folks in the democratic party
spots stop spending money i will that's
the point this is all this is it's not
the end of the world
now we're talking the whole point with
this is what i
love i love that there's a credit limit
i love that there's a limit that's the
best thing that's actually
how the real world is freaking sick now
we're talking yeah
that's the part
you don't want to limit his infinity
thoughts that's
last week i'm buying a bunch of art and
i'm buying stuff at the new house right
conservative but we're two dog people
and one cat
yeah so we're semi-cat i can't
i like you guys i can't deny that don't
try to label him
i forgive you i forgive you about it but
but
but the point last week yeah we're
buying all this art right so jennifer
said cart by the way yeah yeah dude i
can't wait to the main one showed up
today the main ones showing up this
morning i can't
miss the brain watch i can't wait for
that by the way to everybody that sent
the
request to the the different people from
a street artist uh graffiti artist i
took all your recommendations i looked
them up i'm following a lot of those
guys and i got some cool stuff going on
oh i mean i might have a fifth kid if if
my husband would allow me to like nest
and buy art wow
this is nesting jennifer's like listen
the art's on you i just need to make
sure every jennifer's more the
systematic one
so anyway mr mr booth uh danielle's
husband
who doesn't have a first name he's not
having a fifth kid okay i was gonna say
you just you just
admitted you might have a fifth yeah
well we know we're like kids getting fed
food on the floor buddy
get down discipline you got to be tough
but here's the point one of the credit
cards we're spending the guy says
your card didn't go through i'm laughing
it's so funny when the guy's like
you sure yeah i'm like yeah guess what
all right
the credit card limit has a limit so me
as a buyer have to
pay it off and come back and say let me
spend some more so tell the real world i
like
that our government has to pay off their
flipping debt
freaking great women while we've been
sitting here it's like a couple billions
but you know what's crazy here's what's
great here's what it should give the
american people a stroke
because we're paying the damn bill it's
kind of like this let me put it to you
this way
debt per capita debt per tax payer 226
that debt per taxpayer
i would say i'm going to give you the
best example here here's the best
analogy
you rate this analogy 0 to 10 okay
imagine you have a credit card
imagine you as the parent are working
hard to make the money you
are busting your ass except the credit
card is in the hands of your kids
that's what's happening with our
government we're the ones working to pay
off the debt and the
credit card is in the hands of our
politicians they're the kids
the kids these people out there like
yeah let's buy another 1.8 trillion
dollars
now you know spending on that
two-thirds are over the age of 16. so
they're kids they're not spending bad
spending
this is too much 50 years some of these
people have been in congress and they're
still
this bad behavior has got to end by the
way just just so you know our audience
loves when the technical side of daniel
comes out
as crazy as it sounds our audience eats
it up they actually like data
they like hearing it they're like yes
let me get that pen out
put their glasses on right now they're
taking notes yes they're like
you want to know why they're like facts
are powerful yeah facts are much more
persuasive
than opinion i am with you so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye